A travers les époques les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est, c'est, c'est
L'EPOPEE TEMPORELLE !
[Narrateur] Nos héros sont à la recherche de la troisième relique
Qui leur permettra de retrouver le docteur Simon
Ils arrivent au Japon en 1150
Je suis déjà allé au Japon l'été dernier pour mes vacances,
les gens étaient d'une gentillesse INCROYABLE !
En même temps il n'y avait pas de dangereux guerriers samouraïs de l'époque féodale ...
Je vous laisse avec la suite de l'aventure
pendant que je me ressers un verre ...
[Shōgun] Répondez ! Que faites vous ici !
[Thomas] Donc c'est lui le shaugeun !
[Eliot] On dit shōgun
Mouais, moi je préfère dire shaugeun, c'est plus stylé
Très bien, Thomas (force sur le s à la fin de Thomas )
Ca suffit ! Déjà ici, on dit shauguin ! Mais ça dépend des régions.
Et ensuite, comment êtes-vous apparu dans mon palais ?   Etes-vous des esprits ?
[Le pirate] Nan ! On est des "des amis" !
Dans ce cas là, Samouraïs,
Tuez-les ! (les samouraïs sortent leurs sabres)
[Iris] Attendez attendez  !
On est des esprits ! Des amis ET des esprits
Des esprits potes, quoi.
Fort bien ! Dans ce cas vous êtes déjà morts, et vous ne pouvez pas souffrir
Samouraïs, retuez-les !
Nananananan ! Non non, on cherche un objet
Un truc qui vous aurez été donné par quelqu'un en blouse blanche !
Vous voulez parler de...
La relique ancestrale confiée par le grand esprit au manteau aussi blanc que la cime du mont Fuji ?
Eeeeeuuuuuhhhh ouai (?)
Oh oh oh , pauvres FOUS ! JAMAIS JE Ne vous donnerai la relique ancestrale confiée par le grand esprit au manteau aussi blanc que le sim du mont Fuji
[Pirate] Donnez nous la relique, ou alors je vous tue tous !
Mmmmhhh mais de quelle relique parlez vous ?
Bah la relique quoi, le truc dont on parle depuis tout a l'heure !
Oh s'il vous plait, il faut être plus précis. On a plein de reliques ici.
(Hésitante) Ooooooooooooooohhh bah la relique ancestrale confiée par heuuuuuuuuuu
[Eliot] Le grand esprit .
[Thomas] Eeeeeeeeuuuuuuuuh AU MANTEAU, ouais il y avait manteau, aussi blanc que
[Eliot] La cime du (bruitage) Mont Fuji.
Ohhhhh, cette relique ! (rire forcé) C'est non.
Et je vois très bien ce que vous avez essayez de faire, d'ailleurs.
Bien tenté
[Iris] Comment ça ?
Mmmmh votre ami a essayé de nous provoquer en jouant sur notre sens de l'honneur ! Comme si les samouraïs étaient obligés de répondre à n'importe quel défi !
[Pirate] J'ai fais ça moi ? J'ai seulement dit qu'on allait vous tuer si vous ne nous donnez pas ce qu'on veut !
Vous nous avez défiez, c'est tentant mais non !
Donc du coup, si on vous met au défi ...
[Shōgun] C'est inutile.
[Iris] ... de nous donner la relique ...
[Shōgun] Ca ne sert à rien je vous dit .
[Iris]... au nom de l'honneur des samouraïs ?
[Shōgun] Ok nous acceptons le défi. Samouraïs , préparez le tournois !
(Musique style japonaise suivie d'applaudissements)
[Iris] Ah ouai ! Ils ont  construit une arène et il y a déjà des milliers de gens dans les tribunes...  en 1 heure ...
[Pirate] BON ? QUAND EST-CE QU'ON SE BAT ?
[Iris] Bientôt, bientôt,
écoutez, c'est un tournois en 3 matchs
j'ai inscrit Eliot et La Buse dans les 2 premiers matchs
Les gagnants des 2 combats s'affronterons pour le combat final
là on gagne et on récupère la relique.
[Thomas] Très bien, donc moi en fait on me demande même pas de participer, super.
[Iris]  Ahhh ! tu aurais aimé te battre contre les plus grands guerriers du Japon ?
Non non, pas du tout, mais j'aurais aimé qu'on me demande, ensuite j'aurais refusé, parce que c'est comme ça qu'on fait, et là tout le monde aurais été content.
(Foule) Ouaiiiiiiii
[Présentateur] Et bienvenue dans ce grand tournois pour gagner la relique ancestrale confiée par le grand esprit au manteau aussi blanc que la cime du mont Fuji !
[2ème présentateur] Tout a fait, et pour ce premier match, nous avons : "Shigeru le ninja" contre " Eliot" !
L'humain !
Un drôle d'humain si je peux me permettre
[Présentateur] Vous pouvez vous permettre !
(Foule) Ouaiiiiiiii (encore ^^)
[Présentateur] Les adversaires se saluent
[Présentateur 2 ] ET C'EST PARTI !!
Shigeru le ninja sort un shuriken, et le lance de toutes ses forces !
(Le shuriken rebondit et touche Thomas)
[Iris] Thomas !!!
[Présentateur 2] Oh mon dieu ! Le shuriken a rebondit sur Eliot l'humain !
[Présentateur] Le shuriken s'est malencontreusement planté dans le torse d'un jeune homme à coté de l'arêne ! C'est vraiment pas de chance !
[Iris] Thomas, ça va ?
[Thomas] (parle lentement) Je dois te dire ...
[Iris] Oui que tu m'as toujours aimé oui je sais
[Thomas] Ahhh Euuuh no, non, alors pas du tout, je voulais te dire autre chose
[Iris] Eeeeuuuuuh ta pas mal avec l'étoile de ninja planté dans ton coeur ?
[Thomas] Ce qui est planté dans mon coeur, c'est mon amour pour toi
Et ton dédain
[Iris] Mouais, t'as pas l'air de trop souffrir pour faire des métaphores aussi nazes
[Thomas] Hein ? Ah ouai bah en fait c'est un truc qui m'as protégé dans ma veste
Ah c'est fou, les clés d'Aliénor ! Comme quoi il faut toujours garder les objets dans son inventaire, comme dans Skyrim. (mdr)
[Iris] Bon Thomas, va te cacher dans les vestiaires.
Bah pourquoi ?
[Iris] Parce que même si tu te bats pas tu manques de mourrir !
[Présentateur] Le jeune homme qui a manqué de mourrir, rentre dans les vestiaires.
Tandis que
LE MATCH REPREND !!!
(Foule) Ouaiiiiiiii (décidemment !)
[Présentateur 2] Shigeru le ninja saute sur Eliot l'humain, il s'accroche a lui et lui donne des dixaines de coups
Et ne s'arrête PAS !
Mais Eliot l'humain ne réagit PAS !
[Iris] Eliot ! Fait un truc bon sang !
[Pirate] Allez, bats toi !
[Eliot] Je ne peux pas blesser cet humain
[Iris] QUOI ?!? Ah oui c'est vrai c'est contraire aux lois de la robotique d'Asimov, c'est ça ?
[Eliot] Non ! C'est juste que je fais du café ! Je ne suis pas un robot de combat.
[Iris] Mais on s'en fout de ton café ! Il faut ...  Nan mais attends, je sais !
KB-28, tu peux me servir un truc ?
[Eliot] A votre service Iris
Sers à mon ami ninja ici présent, 6 litres de café brûlant sans tasse directement dans ses yeux
[Eliot] 6 litres de café robuste et ultra chaud servit directement dans vos yeux pour votre bon plaisir
(cri de douleur + foule qui crie ohhh)
[Présentateur 2]  Oooohhhhhh !!!
[Ninja] MES YEUX, MES DEUX YEUX !!! AAARRRGGHHHH
[Présentateur 1] Il titube, et il tombe ...
[Les deux présentateurs] PAR DESSUS LA TROISIEME CORDE !
[Eliot] 1 ou 2 sucres ?
[Présentateur 2] Shigeru le ninja est K.O par brûlure aux yeux !
[Présentateur 1] Quand on vous disait que les ninjas n'avaient pas froid aux yeux !
[Présentateur 2] Excellent jeu de mot !
Eliot l'humain gagne le premier match !
[Iris] Wahou ! Yes, ça a marché !
[Pirate] Bravo mon des amis de fer !
(nouvelle musique style japonnaise)
[Présentateur 2]Et c'est parti pour le deuxième match !
Takashi, le grand samouraï,
la fierté de la nation, contre la buse, le pirate de taille moyenne
Les adversaires se saluent et ...
Oh mon dieu !
Le pirate de taille moyenne, ce saligaud, vient de donner un coup à Takeshi, PENDANT LE SALUT !
[Pirate] Il a baissé la tête, bien sûr que je le frappe !
[Présentateur] 1 point de pénalité pour la buse .
[Pirate] J'cromprends rien moi ...
[Iris] La buse, t'as le droit qu'a 3 points de pénalité !
[Pirate] C'est quoi des points de pénalité ? On invente des mots ou on se bat ici ?
[Iris] C'est bon tu peux y aller maintenant mais fais attention !
[Pirate] Enfin !
[Présentateur] Le pirate de taille moyenne sort sa hache et s'élance vers le samouraï, et ...
AAAAHHHHHH
(foule) ooooohhhhh
Ah je suis tombée !
[Iris] Aliénor ?!
[Présentateur] Mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
[Aliénor] Mais ou suis-je encore moi ?
[Présentateur 2] Quelqu'un vient d'apparaître sur le terrain !
[Iris] Sors du terrain !
[Aliénor] Quoi, qu'avez vous dit Dame Iris ?
[Pirate ]Dégage de là !
[Aliénor] Excusez-moi ...
[Pirate] J'suis en train de me battre tu vois pas ?
Enfant de p°tain !
[Présentateur] Oula oh ! Deuxième point de pénalité pour vulgarité !
[Aliénor] Comment osez-vous me parler ? Je ne suis pas venue ici pour souffrir (ok?) c'est entendu ? Espèce de gros dégeu...
[Présentateur 2] Et la personne à disparue du terrain ! C'est très clairement un yo-kai qui a été invoqué !
[Présentateur] Oui très clairement, un Yo-Kai, ces très célebres esprits japonais...
[Pirate] Bon, je peux me battre maintenant ?
[Présentateur 2] Aïe Aïe Aïe, tout le monde sait que l'invoquation de yo-Kai est formellement interdite par le règlement des tournois pour gagner des reliques ancestrales confiés par des grands esprits aux manteaux aussi blancs que la cime du Mont Fuji
Un coup de poing, un gros mots et une invoquation de Yo-Kai, ça fais 3 pénalités. Il est disqualifié !
[Iris]Oh nan ...
[Pirate] Disfaliquié ? (c'est fait exprès)
[Iris] Ca veut dire que tu as perdu la buse.
[Pirate] QUOI ? Mais c'est quoi ce pays ou on peut même pas se battre ?
Eeeeeettttttttt c'est Takashi, le grand samouraï, la fierté de la nation qui gagne !
[Présentateur] La finale verra s'affronter Takashi le grand samouraï, la fierté de la nation, contre Eliot l'hum... Attendez, on vient de me donner une information capitale,
Oh non quoi encore ?
Eliot l'humain N'EST PAS UN HUMAIN !
QUOI, MAIS POURTANT C'EST DANS SON NOM !!
[Eliot] Mais si voyons, je suis un humain, je fais des trucs d'humains, regardez, je vais euh manger ce litchi
Miam !
Délicieux ce fructose !
[Iris] Oh non, t'aurais pu faire l'effort d'enlever la peau d'abord !
Apparement le moment ou Eliot a sortit 6 litres de liquide bouillant de son ventre a mis les arbitres sur la piste !
Pas Du tout heu j'était en train de heu uriner ?
Personnèlement j'ai gouté et c'était pas du tout de l'urine
Pourquoi ta gouté ? Oh ça va c'est bon c'était pas de l'urine. Mais quand t'as gouté tu croyais que c'était de l'urine ? Mais c'était pas de l'urine !
Eliot l'humain n'était pas un humain ! Il est disqualifié !
[Pirate] Et bah on est pareil mon des amis !
[Iris] Et merde qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? Je...moi, moi je le remplace !
[Présentateur 1] Hélas les femmes sont à peine des humains aussi.
[Iris] Quoi ? Il est sérieux là ?
[Présentateur 1]  Seul un homme de votre équipe qui ne c'est pas encore battu, peut participer a la finale .
[Iris] Oh nan ...
[Présentateur 1] Si vous n'avez personne, vous perdez immédiatement !
[Iris] Ok, ok ...
[Présentateur 1] Alors, avez-vous un remplaçant ?
[Iris] (marmonne) bah oui mais nan mais oui bah...
Thomas !...
(Foule) Ouaiiiiiiii (ça n'en finira jamais !)
(Foule) Thomas (en accentuant le s à la fin)
[Eliot] Ah ! Je savais qu'on prononçait comme ça !
[Pirate] Ah c'est balot... J'l'aimais bien ...
[Thomas] J'étais dans les vestiaires et j'ai entendu mon nom ... Il se passe un truc ?
[Narrateur] Il se passe que le prochain épisode s'annonce épique !
Un dangereux samouraï fait face a Thomas, qui demande de l'aide à sa mère pour ouvrir les pots de cornichons ! Quel combat excitant ...
Vous découvrirez la fin du tournoi de
一時的なエピック！
C'est le nom japonais de l'épopée temporelle .
[Cyprien] Merci d'avoir écouté le 8ème épisode de l'épopée temporelle, n'hésite pas à mettre un pouce en l'air pour les sous titres ! A t'abonner et à la semaine prochaine !